so let's go back to title intro and
we're gonna take out its role as a push
right so we're gonna have them ease up
on the push but yes it keep this prompt
I want you to pay attention to the point
in space that my elbow is this elbow
will go forward continually in its
pattern so it's going to turn this way
so here's my point my elbows point in
space and it moves forward into that
pattern making this wrong so it's not
going to go backwards it's not going to
go down it's going to go forward into
the pattern this pattern is a circular
so my elbow is not going to draw a
straight line here so it's moving
forward on the pattern a step to keep it
going and then a step to stay connected
to the tunnel so market in space it goes
forward step to keep connected to that
pattern step to stay connected to the
power the pattern is marked by
consistency symmetry grace beauty so
it's just a continuous gradual extent
of the spiral me it does not change so I
started out and now I'm going to cut it
across you see that or I change hi
no seeds Aggie no abrupt corners just a
continuation
mark it keep it going
said to keep it going watch your last
step that's where you're going off it
mess up so okay good I mean go by
I won't forward I go and now you just
ignore this part this elbow will cut
across here and you're going to try to
push back is that elbow zigzag back just
work on the elbows pass through space
boom step to keep it spot okay let's
give you some mine free pointers you
should be able just to do but you start
thinking
so let's just look at his center of
gravity balance basis support if I push
this bot do you feel that okay so my
elbow back to the pattern point my elbow
is going too far forward into the
pattern that the pattern goes from here
on to the curve do you see that so if I
push here the elbow is going in a
straight line that was not the problem
okay when I go into straight line at
higher speeds that would be a clash and
you would be bounced off if he had way
more could generate more cookie okay
you're going Yong to y'all energy wise
so you won't have I to it won't happen
your classroom okay but you actually
give him back his base you're
stabilizing you're stabilizing his basic
support for forward progress need this
place to take his balance is to have
this 7 right here you see I'm pushing
into his back leg
if I add the curve I'm gonna make him
fall forward you think he has to just
don't move your feet no matter what
don't move your feet no matter what so I
want to come forward on the curves but
its energy goes here then next note the
pattern so it goes on our first with the
hip the foot has not moved yet keep the
distance equal between your elbow under
ribcage where do you get your range from
with the rotation you don't get your
range from the step or the arm extension
rotate that'll be the hole that's where
you step into the free space so you
don't challenge the space here you don't
challenge the space here you move in or
you let it move that way and then you
step where the elbow pattern needs it
you see it's all free space here and I'm
pivot on a single pivot point the back
leg there's no weight on the other leg
which is why it can move so immediately
he goes this way I step to keep the
pattern going on the elbow single pivot
point then step to keep it that's where
he wants to go step to keep the pattern
do you see how I shifting weight come
back
watch me double pivot here's the gear I
step I'm going to double pivot now I'm
going to pull them you see that when I
shift weight onto the other leg I'm on
the other side of the axis of rotation
so there's the hole for the EDB step
into it keep it going
don't double pivot here you're gonna
pull him shift weight on the line
that will allow this leg this is
dreaming here but mostly you like that
boom step
this language straight back violence
pull shift weight pull straight back
this way
watch right step here was the original
12 six line you see that you're stepping
as if he was still there
my step
there seem so where was the 12 to 6 line
on the other side of it this way he's
actually rotating around okay see if I
step here there's some imaginary
two-dimensional vectoring that I go home
I want the sidewalk I don't want to be
on the side of it I start him rotating
around you see all right so take out now
we took out bouquets roll we're going to
take out the internal aspects we're just
going to look at the external yin
aspects okay so when I do this pattern
you see how it gets kind of tight in
there you see that right right in there
and I kind of hovering on the surface of
that pressure the mistake that some of
you were making at first was you cross
the pressure line you see okay to help
me not get so tight there I'm going to
keep the same pattern the same thing
that makes the center go this way but I
rotate my arm harmoniously with the top
you see that so there is the outer
spiral of the overall pattern and then
an interior spiral of the arm for
okay so we're here and how you can tell
is that his grip is going to go up
underneath okay
now the problem is if I go underneath
look what happened to my alma mater he
came across and disclosed this base
closed here so you can't turn all at
once and it can't turn independently of
the hip so as the elbow goes down they
hit turns to keep the length do you see
that and then everything is the same so
we're going to do it static at first
meaning but she's already pushed into
them okay now I do the hip and this
elbow drops underneath that's it that's
all I need right there and then I keep
the pattern go hip elbow connection hip
forward elbow down now hold down if you
exaggerated it too much that elbow
linesman cut across
so it's very small that's it that was it
right there that's it and once you get
it you can now start bending the time at
home was right and that way there's no
boom he goes right into it and boom we
do static won't that's it
it's very long I'm gonna think about a
quarter-inch
it's about wordage wool won't shift stay
in Porter Ranch home hip it up feel it
in there
okay yeah so wait why wait my elbow
travels straight like this you end up
pulling on the fingers okay when you
when you have your elbow right in place
then I'm actually pushing on his palm so
the energy is going like this the energy
is not going like this so hit get let's
have some fun okay so right here this is
actually all if you could we would do
this but you wouldn't get it this is all
I need for the for the entire technique
[Music]
and that's not gonna push hard see that
to see my difference okay so you have to
watch that pattern the other thing don't
and you're going to do that every time
you do this every time or every time you
ask too much of your hip rotation do you
see everything has this natural
beginning and natural end so there was
nothing wrong with rolling the elbow
underneath but when it started to go too
far you see it now it messed up so it
has its lifecycle aside from its pattern
so the same thing here
all this is fine I stopped right and
then if I go here I didn't continue in
DC and now I'm back to the pulling thing
and the elbow to and rib cage pattern
closed which means I don't have that
hard Center where if he pushes on me he
bounces off of me you understand so for
example he's powerful again right and I
go here he's pushing at me we're not
gonna go in he's gonna go somewhere you
see but when I'm here like this and I
have a pulling energy and he said I'm
gonna have to do something else but he's
gonna knock you down okay so if you keep
the pattern we keep this energetic
integrity in here which is key for
weapon fighting okay so there's a timing
to it I have to keep it in mind of what
I'm doing so so then it hasn't so that
it's natural so just like a vampire
[Music]
that is unnatural okay same thing if you
can't have booze that don't die they do
they have to pass through your natural
cycle
not just the form of things okay when
that way I'm always kind of pushing but
really it's that we got stuck together
okay so Wolfe John without their stuff
together it doesn't take anything you do
the other one right we're gonna like
this I know you're feeling it is
challenging your stats to his pull it on
your stance when we start getting these
goofy things either in the shape
or balance problems or even just feet
wheelie feet Wiggly is not right all
right if he Wiggly now no nobody's
pushing on me so they should not be
wiggling in the technique - they don't
wiggle in the technique okay let's go
[Music]
here we are on this line on the knife
hey he's pushing I'm doing this same
drill watch where I'm stepping what did
I tell you I step in relation to what
nope
the pattern of the elbow okay so for
example watch what happens if I step
towards Leah
I changed the distance between my
ribcage and my elbow and that elbow now
starts to move linearly across okay so
we're here first move I'm not staying in
connection to my elbow but to what end
what would be too much if that was too
far whatever laughs yeah what okay G
when why would it go in oh why
okay say there that's right okay
remember I wanted to be neutral I'm not
pulling I'm not pushing and not young
I'm not yet I'm zero pressure okay so I
do the first part whoa
and I step to keep zero pressure so
stepping over here I felt that increase
the dog can't step there if I step over
here I feel it decrease too much so I
step over here to keep it going around
you get that okay now let's free your
mind why when I have this 12 the six
line and my going on the negative side
do you see I step too far out why why
why would it be gonna do that
yeah yeah your mind is stuck on the
original 12 to 6 line do you understand
ok but what what was the 10 of the 12 to
6 line even when you got stuck on it I
this wasn't right you see that that was
not right why was that wrong do this
more than you need right is too much of
a break this side so you set only what
you needed to do so for example if he's
doing ski right I only need that pitch I
don't go like this
right ok so even if I don't understand 0
the line excessively but as I said what
it's important is right now I have a
conflict which is why he's on 12 and I'm
on 6
what if I wasn't on 6 and I became the
middle of the claw you understand now I
don't have 12 opposing 6 so whoa I come
around here and you see at this moment
if you took a picture you wouldn't know
which technique that was but you can
tell he's going around me easy so get
off the oppositional geometry you're
trying to reconcile the 12 to 6 conflict
whoa whoa he's going around you okay so
you have to step in that's generally
what's going to have to happen for you
to keep the pattern whoa you're going to
have to go here across you see how
across with all the same and I keep
turning that way he goes around me go
back hey whoa when I go like this he's
not going around me you see that and not
Rahmi and as I call them okay let's go
so your heart is always made up of let's
just generalize it okay so when I took
when I come here to sit the same
mechanics that allow me not to pull and
to put to push him through the pattern
and thus a mechanics that take his bowel
is there which keep it moving forward
right
is this a mechanic's that made me be
bhai or if you want a head on the spiral
at the contention point so he can't push
on me okay so what do I mean by that so
as he's falling that way do you see and
as I move this way this you can if I
stay here you can push on it you can
push on me see but we're going to keep
moving and now I'm past the contention
point you see and the only way he can
push now is to do what he has to push
back but he can't push back on because
he was going forward I could get that
back the only way you can pull is if
you're on the other side of that spiral
so when you go like this you see and
when you're pulling like that
push into you and get you you understand
so if you see your your elbows get
smashed in you're like that so they
pushed in you or your stances like that
or you're having to lean to keep
yourself upright it's because you
violated those rules you did not get
ahead of the contention point on the
spiral which would be there is no
contention point do you understand that
so he's a bull and he's never who can
push on me if he does who shot me what's
he actually doing he's moving forward
you see that which means he's moving it
away from being able to push them okay
let's go okay
timing to have that baby geometry to get
the basic cultivation so you really
really talk oh that's what I want boom
boom boom I'm just doing this same trail
twice so hip out then not this
just elbow your connection boom my arms
are buried he's he's trying but my arms
are very loose so you're pulling him
it's not the same he feels it feels
empty see he pushes and he just keeps
going that way you see that there are
the dog whoa because the arm is relaxed
he's just pushing into the ground boom
let it die he comes up if I shove this
back now
his body boos back he's not off-balance
okay he anybody that look at it this way
my Kido Kazushi is sometimes I have a
bottom force that's keeping his face
from recovering his bounce so if I don't
have that leg there and I push he
recovered his balance by moving his base
of support so sometimes I have a base
there that you can't recover but most
times I'm using the nurse his face is
gone that way so I don't want to stop
this base move on that way so I'm not
gonna go here and then I stop him I'm
you think you're gonna do this and
you're gonna stay there and then you're
gonna accelerate your back on that lot
that's not it right here right oh so you
can see how he gets trapped up top on me
right because his body's actually
that way do you understand different
different if I bought this too stiff
you're dreaming you still gotta take the
kid keep your integrity though don't let
your knees cape
boom he's going this way if he could
turn he was not going that way you see
that so if they're able to get the turn
on you that wood they're trying to
regain their balance okay which means
he's not he does do kind of flying
graceful but he's not
[Music]
you can see it's fairly any entry
okay got it so if they're turning on you
you're pulling on that or you're not
letting to go in and out and they can
turn themselves where you pulling on
them and you stop them so on that way
they can turn themselves are you
returning them okay all right stop one
trouble okay just really driving and
just free it
[Music]
baby see he push it it's not in there
this is all these all let's keep pushing
hard use two hands keep pushing this
this is all not important now I'm not
going to like this
I'm not going like this right I'm not
doing that
okay I'm this walk generates pressure
for you
whoa generates pressure free at this
corner at this corner boom generation
fresh shirt like Valastro last week I
miss pressure you're going down boom
free boom free
pressure free pressure top this is
buffering right yeah pressure were hip
elbow down pressure oh okay everything
okay it's easier that way
wait that's not what we were doing okay
just just like just like racing angle is
incorrect right grandpa is go ahead
ground path is also it is also not
important top is not important your four
corners was very important and now way
to make it not important okay so your
football you're locking it out okay I
want this one I want you let go of one I
just want you like
it's out of a relationship I'll try to
stop it as as we go it's out all right
this our relationship okay this should
have been here you see that so our
relationship
pushy gets the pressure and then I let
it out a relationship so you can come
feel feel feel the tension just so you
feel my muscles okay here and then get a
solid feel like you're gonna feel it all
just shut it off okay we're not him in
here and I released right
then he pushes me into the pot Oh see
when we first started do you like but if
I do everything right when he pushes and
I screen the bottom the front hip corner
he will push into that other arm hi hi
okay so I am now not that agent I just
do that and keep that power which is
easy
I'm here he's pushing am i free
yeah
so there's no pull a my staff cannot be
challenged there's none of that he
pushes home free time in if you just
like the other week work you need to
generate the pressure holes you can feel
it feel it and then you're going to free
it if you want you can do that but if
you're already getting it then you
should do it right on the right others
are right when he touches you free it
won't free and move okay